I feel like I'm at the worst like
wedding cake tasting in the whole world
it's like the wedding of the apocalypse
[Music]
when I think of survival food I
automatically think that I'm gonna eat a
bug survival food is what you keep in
your apocalypse bunker like a can of
beans or some Twinkies that you grabbed
with your hands from a stream when
you're lost yeah I'm a past Boy Scout
and survival food is like MREs which is
meals ready to eat I'm very nervous I
have no idea what's in this food what
we're about to eat I mean it doesn't
look bad oh so it's just a packet that's
free stride and then you add water into
it these chunks look like cat food to me
survival food or probably college food
to college Cheers
this is pretty good I mean it's got
flavor the chicken kind tastes like fish
maybe airplane good I'm not going back
for another bucket I mean if I was on a
budget you know I only had a few dollars
can I eat it all
it's pretty good I would definitely eat
this chicken and rice before I would eat
a person yeah
[Music]
it doesn't look like any food I've ever
seen like this looks like astronaut food
maybe we're gonna break it to think if a
crumb cake and a rock [ __ ]
is it weird I imagine that in my head oh
it's really hard I'm tough to bite into
well it's got flavor like a strawberry
Laffy Taffy but like someone like messed
up and forgot to put all the strawberry
in there I know it doesn't actually know
it wants to it's got like choc flavor
can't even break it in half is
unbreakable
I think it was I can't even I guess like
if those zombies are coming you could
throw this at them and it wouldn't like
her dad also be doubled as a weapon
is this cheese it looks like the crust
of like a pie that didn't want finish it
looks like a fry and Parmesan cheese
much softer than that other thing this
is something you'd find in like the
99-cent store this is really good I feel
like I would like snack on if you had
some peanut butter on this and that
would probably be really good I'd
probably go and look for a fish in the
stream or something I think I would
probably eat this while I was looking
for the fish in the stream
[Music]
this looks like the bag that dog treats
survival tabs full meals in one little
piece of candy
smells like lip gloss for children do
you smell lip gloss for children often
yeah this looks like what I throw in
right like with my laundry is it true
it's real bad I don't like this it's
very chalky like it looks this better as
your nipple it's a creaminess but you're
like why is it creamy there was nothing
creamy and I'd rather eat a person it's
like I'm gonna eat my neighbor before
I'm eating these creamy tabs there are
some nutrients in it my mouth feels
weird now
I'm not feels like a survivor you can
survive three weeks without having any
food in your body I could survive a few
hours I can't even like install an AC
you know although I will say that like
pretty okay with like eating bugs after
you've been hiking for like eight or ten
hours you would lit literally eat like
dog crap I mean people have eaten people
before because they're hungry and I
survived because I hiked for eight hours
you know I have an insatiable appetite
[Music]